[Music]
Howie to Harry Harry Howie Howie Harry
did you have any idea that she would
become the global icon yes I called her
Duchess she knows that I called her
Duchess here's what bothers me she's
going to the wedding I didn't say that I
know but she's going how we tossed a
briefcase bubs our Mike but really went
off the rails when we asked Mel B about
a Spice Girl hookup
Mel I would do want to ask you I don't
know if you knew but then sink out there
sir from the walk of fame and they were
on Ellen never have I ever hooked up
with a psycho let's go rumors are that
it's Baby Spice so what I'm not saying
anything I think I know I'll just say it
right here okay Baby Spice No okay how
we back to the Royal Wedding and all the
buzz about a Spice Girl performance you
met Prince Harry at the spice world
premiere what do you remember at that
time what gray the great kids
Melanie B will you be at the wedding
will you perform I'm I saw you have no
idea I think she's gonna be at the
wedding performing do I think she was
invited no I think there's gonna be
people at tables going with Mel B over
there alone singing and performing we
didn't want her here we didn't ask her
to be part of this
she shows up to everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]